Hey, everyone,
we're gonna be taking a look at this concept of making ...
decisions at the margin.
Now let's ask ourselves the question,
should we hire one more worker?
Should we subscribe to another streaming service?
Our smart choices don't rely on gut feelings.
In fact, they're made at the margin.
Let's break this down on how marginal analysis actually ...
works and how it helps us make better decisions in ...
business and in life.
So here we have the rules.
We have our marginal cost and our marginal revenue.
Marginal cost is the cost of doing one more unit or ...
making one more unit.
Marginal revenue is the extra income that we generate from ...
selling that unit.
Now, we have three simple rules ...
that go along with this, with these two concepts or definitions.
The first is if our marginal revenue is greater than our ...
marginal cost, then we want to do more,
produce more, sell more,
because we can earn extra profit from doing so.
Our second one is if our marginal revenue is less than ...
our marginal costs, then we want to do less,
because now every extra unit of output that we sell actually ...
cost us more than what we bring in.
And that leads us to the golden rule,
which is where marginal revenue equals marginal cost.
We can't actually do any better than this.
We're at our profit maximizing point.
So when we're making decisions at the margin as a ...
business, we always want to keep in ...
mind what is our marginal revenue,
what is our marginal cost?
Because if we know those two,
we know that we can equate them.
At that level of output, we will maximize our profit.
Now, let's consider this bakery here.
They're considering hiring some extra workers.
And in this graphic, we can clearly see that ...
marginal revenue is always less than marginal cost.
That is, marginal revenue seems to ...
be growing as our output grows.
So that lets us know they're going to hire some workers ...
beyond whatever makes six units of output.
But let's look at this table here.
Something a little bit more realistic for this bakery.
We have workers numbering one to five output,
or our cookies that we are selling,
that goes from 100 to 180, 240,
280, and 300.
At five workers, our marginal revenue falls ...
from $200 at one worker all the way to $40 at five workers.
But our marginal costs are constant,
no matter how many workers we employ.
So in this example, we are trying to figure out ...
where is our marginal revenue greater than,
or, excuse me,
equal to our marginal cost?
And we don't really have anywhere where marginal ...
revenue was equal to 150.
But we do have an area where marginal revenue is ...
equal to 160, which is greater than ...
marginal costs.
But then if we go to the third worker,
our marginal revenue is 120.
So now our marginal revenue is less than our marginal ...
cost, which means that we actually ...
want to hire just two workers.
In this case, this is going to give us the ...
closest approximation of when marginal revenue ...
equals marginal cost, and that is how many workers ...
we want to hire.
Let's consider adding another streaming subscription.
So we're going to move from the business realm to the ...
personal realm.
And when we look at adding another streaming ...
subscription, we want to again,
think at the margin, how many extra hours per ...
week are we going to spend watching this new streaming service?
So we have four streaming services below.
Netflix, Hulu,
Disney plus and Paramount plus.
And we have the hours watched per week on each of ...
those services.
Now notice what happens with our marginal revenue.
That is, in this case,
it's the value or enjoyment that we get.
And it goes from high to moderate to low to negligible.
And our monthly cost here is worth it,
worth it marginal and not worth it.
So again, we are equating our marginal ...
revenue to our marginal cost.
And if we're trying to consider whether or not to add that ...
fourth, in this case Paramount plus ...
subscription, we see that the marginal ...
revenue of negligible is.
And the marginal cost of not worth it really doesn't make it ...
to the point where we want to spend that extra $15. So.
So we probably will stop at Disney,
where the marginal revenue that we get is low.
And that's somewhat equivalent to marginal as into ...
the monthly cost.
Now, let's consider one last aspect ...
in our marginal decisions, and that's ignoring some of ...
these particular costs, like sunk cost.
Now, what we have here is this ...
tired developer.
They've already spent an hour,
100 hours logged into coding this game,
and they are completely burnt out.
Now what we have to keep in mind is those 100 hours are a sunk cost.
Those are hours that coder is not going to get back.
So the coder is trying to decide,
do they keep coding with them feeling miserable with ...
all the coding, or do they start something new?
Is the next venture worth worth it?
In this case, if you are completely burnt ...
out, ignore the 100 hours that ...
you've already logged and start something new,
get something fresh going on.
Ignore those sunk costs.
Ignore those fixed costs that you've already incurred that ...
you cannot get back.
We've already logged the 100 hours,
we cannot get them back.
Perhaps the only thing that we can potentially get back is ...
taking that code bits of that code and applying it to the new project.
Particularly in this case, if that old project,
if you don't feel like it's worth it anymore,
then the extra hour that you spend is not going to help ...
your situation.
So ignore those irrelevant costs that we have already ...
incurred and move forward into that new project.
All right, that is it for this decisions at ...
the margin, and I hope you have enjoyed it.